thank you mr schmitt appointed member of
the european commission by the european council
after the vote of approval by the european parliament
i solemnly undertake to respect
the treaties the charter of
fundamental rights of the european union in
the performance of all my duties at
exercise my responsibilities in full
independence in the general interest of
the union in the performance of my
tasks requested nor
accept instructions from any government,
institution, body or organization to
abstain from any act incompatible
with the character of  my functions or
the performance of my tasks
I take note of the obligation established by
the Treaty on the Functioning of
the European Union under which
each Member State must respect this
character and not seek to
influence the members of the Commission
in  the execution of their tasks
I further undertake to respect during
the duration of my functions and after
the cessation of these  ions
arising from my office, in particular the
duty of honesty and delicacy
as to the acceptance after this
cessation of certain functions or
certain advantages
thank you